[Music]
when on in the cost at the women wash
teaching I always grew up with a passion
for cause and especially I still
when you're in the car the world is
playing you doing what you love and you
forget about all your other
[Music]
I'm Kaylen I'm 17 years old and one of
the top female spinners in South Africa
spinning is the fastest-growing x3
motorsport in South Africa spinning
started off as illegal because people
stole cars and Spanish as a sign of
celebration it became legal now because
we do it or at a control dinner
competitions not normally charged by a
panel of judges they set out the track
and they ask you to complete it in the
one who tries it without touching the
cone or pumping the tires
[Music]
[Music]
my father was the one who bought me the
car and then got me into the spinning my
car special to me because it's modified
to my advantage
like the suit is higher because I'm very
tiny
[Music]
we basically freeze them most of the
time we keep the Paquin's burning so
that it's always smoking until the type
of you have to be able to control a car
better yeah
hey Rin full of female Spanish but I
wish there was more it's great to be one
of the few women in the sport it just
shows that you have the ability to do
anything you put your mind to I
[Music]
definitely see myself as a role model
not to just women but to guys as well
because this mini date asked me to teach
them how to spin they want to be like me
someday
[Music]
in the spinning culture we more of a
family like in anything goes wrong
mostly not always scheme to help one
another
[Music]
spelling has taught me a lot like a test
total to be confident myself it has
taught me that or whether you make
mistakes it doesn't matter just carry on
driving you will get through it's all
worth it because it's my passion
[Music]
you